for kelly hedrick traveling to another
country suddenly seems less difficult it
definitely changes everything it's much
easier with kids the federal government
isn't discouraging non-essential travel
outside canada anymore and travelers no
longer require a pcr test to get into
the country we still have to do the
antigen test but it's less expensive
it's less time consuming we have so few
vacation days who wants to spend that
like hunting down a test at a medical
office antigen tests are still needed
but those pcr tests are not the old
requirement kept many travelers from
leaving canada
definitely yes i think i think we will
think less before we travel now it's
easier to just make a quick plan
gabrielle lepage is traveling to the u.s
for a family emergency he's not entirely
sure the changes are good i'm not
necessarily comfortable with the lifting
of the restrictions but at some point we
have to move on right i think this is
kind of a breaking point for us where
we're starting to see that light at the
end of the tunnel light that's expected
to drive a surge in travel in time for
march break it's like it's a lot more
flexible i guess tara freeman lives in
boston she says the canadian approach to
the pandemic is in stark contrast to
what she sees at home
it feels way more taken seriously here
than anywhere else fewer restrictions
will likely mean more americans and
other visitors coming here and a caution
travelers still need to be prepared no
matter where you're going you do need to
be aware that
things could change you need to do your
research you need to make sure that you
can get those rapid tests assuming you
don't want to take more expensive pcr
tests it's been a long time since kelly
hendrick flew anywhere i was pregnant
with him the last time i went on a plane
and he's almost three now taking her son
asher for a trip long postponed
grandparents for the first time
kelly's story mirroring so many others
we've heard about people that held off
on travel because of the cost because of
the pandemic because of uncertainty
cost again was a big one and of course
that government advisory not to travel
for non-essential reasons those rule
changes gone the belief is many more
people are planning to fly now